merry christmas i'm so excited to be  here with you we've been working hard  and having a lot of fun on the new  season of gwen calls the heart  right now though from us to you here's a  never-before-seen clip  you're gonna love it  oh  all right give her a shot ah  look at that there you go hey jesse  thank you  thank you so much yeah it's my pleasure  i'm sorry mrs thornton i'm really really  sorry i'm sure that you are  i've just i've never ridden before and i  wanted to sit up on the saddle  and then i just kicked him like this no  more kicking we'll discuss this when we  get back to town  at least you don't have to take sergeant  for a ride later  lively little town you have here yeah we  try  how was that for a sneak peek we can't  wait for you to see the all new season  of when calls the heart coming in the  new year  it might just be the biggest and best  season yet but for now stay cozy  we've got more wayne calls the heart  home for christmas coming up